[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena o
podcast semanal onde a gente di troca
ideias sobre conteúdos que a gente leu
ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo uma visão
de produto PR discussão sou Artur depois
de TRS
semanas não vai ter mais curso esse
final de semana eu sou a assim como
artes de eu não ter dado semanas de
curso acho que eu também estou torcendo
pro próximo final de semana chegar no
programa de hoje a gente vai falar sobre
um tema só que é sobre pensamento
crítico e analítico veja só que tema
conveniente não é Artur porque qual que
foi o último curso do
arenda cara vai até parece ser um Jabá
aqui né já engatando no jabá mas é enfim
acabou a semana de a sequência aí de
três finais de semana seguidos com
cursos Eh agora a gente vai ter uma
próxima rodada no final de junho e julho
também vão ser algumas semanas vão ser
duas semanas direta mas eu queria trazer
antes de falar do Jabá aqui eu queria
trazer o que que a galera que participou
do último curso de pensamento crítico e
analítico falou a Andressa Ribeiro que é
Senior PM na RD Station falou um dia que
nem senti o tempo passar conteúdo super
rico real e necessário e a Line que é
Senior PM do food mandou foi um dia de
muito aprendizado eu não sabia que eu
precisava tanto desse curso até eu fazer
esse curso
e Enfim então assim não é são os os
próprios participantes disseram e a
gente vai ter mais duas rodadas de curso
do pensamento crítico analítico dia
29/06 vai ser online ao vivo então para
você que é de fora de São Paulo ou que
não não consegue ir no presencial mesmo
t em São Paulo dia 29/6 tem dia 6/07 aí
sim vai ser presencial lá na nossa casa
no escritórios da juus Então é isso e o
também se você acha que é só isso não é
dia
20/07 conhecido como Julho né sábado em
julho vai ter mais uma edição do curso
de ai para PMs terceira Edição a ikira
vai tá lá também falando do do chat gp
do GP que ele fez e vamos ter várias
coisinhas também e o link tá na
descrição com aquele descontinho Maroto
de sempre demais agora sim bora lá pra
paa Bora
[Música]
lá então né esse bloco eu sei que tá
parecendo meio Jabá aqui mas é É sério
que ele é Genuino uma discussão porque
depois que a gente fez essas últimas
edições eh e com os os vários feedbacks
que a gente recebeu eh a gente viu que
como que esse lance de pensamento
crítico e analítico como conseguir
conectar as mudanças que você faz no
produto com os indicadores financeiros
da companhia e tudo mais não é tão
discutido e como já é um papo que eu e o
ikira sempre que que dá a gente conversa
sobre eu ia falar isso né não é como se
a gente nunca tivesse falado nisso aqui
no podcast antes dos cursos né Pois é e
e a gente quis trazer para discutir um
pouco mais sobre isso também aqui com os
nossos queridos
ouvintes Mas então tá para para começar
Que queesse tal de pensamento crítico e
analítico né eu vou parafrasear o Dudu e
meu parceiro do curso né E que já
apareceu aqui no podcast também falando
sobre proops
eh mas a frase dele para isso é a
capacidade de avaliar um problema
examinando Fatos e informações que
fortaleçam ou invalidem um ponto de
vista lógico considerando relações de
causa e
efeito profundo né pareceu bem me parece
profundo isso o Dudu tem o dom da
palavra
eh mas e aí a como que você explica o
que que é pensamento crítico que
analítico assim me falta o dom da
palavra tal qual o Dudu né falar
mandou um tal qual aí já já
[Música]
já cara Acho que a forma como eu penso
isso é é bem separado assim os dois
conceitos né de crítica e de análise
dentro disso então mas primeiro pensar
criticamente é você tirar vieses você
conseguir olhar para um problema e
enxergar ele da menor forma ali sabe
reduzir ao máximo esse esse problema e
tirar todos os elementos ali para que
você
possa entender a que que ele se a que
que ele se resume né então você entender
o problema de fato e não o que você acha
do problema o que outra pessoa acha ou
que todos os componentes do mundo
fizeram esse problema aparecer e aí a
parte analítica da coisa quando a gente
fala de de ser analítico muitas pessoas
pensam logo em D doos análise
quantitativa né e eu acho que é é sobre
isso também mas é sobre você pensar
Quais são as coisas que você
precisa analisar em si né para entender
aquele problema para entender o tamanho
dele para entender possibilidades e aí
vai muito naquela coisa que a gente
sempre fala aqui de como você quebra um
problema e como você resolve as partes
desse problema identifica a causa raiz
desse problema através dessa quebra né
então como você torna um negócio grande
menor através de olhar para ele de forma
criticamente como você entende eh essas
partes menores eh analisando-as né de
forma mais e ali então um pouquinho bem
menos resumido do que o d do trás aí né
mas é um pouquinho da forma que eu
enxergue Ach que tem muito a ver com
várias coisas que a gente fala aqui de
resolução de problema
eh e outras coisas me lembrou até um
pouco sabe o quê do livro lá Thinking
bats né eu eu pensei eu tava pensando
nele porque ele fala muito sobre isso de
você tirar vieses né Eh principalmente
de você discutir com outras pessoas é e
quando a gente tá falando do Lance
crítico é é isso né Como você consegue
levantar os argumentos meio que são
contra e a favor baseado em Pontos de
vistas ou informações que você tenha
esse é um exercício que eu sempre gosto
de fazer que é eh que entra até um pouco
na linha dos riscos lá do kean ou coisas
do tipo mas eu sempre gosto de fazer de
cara tá bom tem uma parada então assim
no meu melhor cenário como pode ser no
meu pior cenário como pode ser e se e
possíveis coisas podem acontecer então
quando quando é alguma coisa né que vai
para mas assim também isso na tomada da
decisão um pouco usando esses fatores
também né tipo assim tá bom Quais são as
coisas a favor disso e quais são as
coisas contras com relação a esse ponto
então tão simples quanto abr um slide e
sai tacando essas inform caixinha para
Tá bom pode dar ruim pode dar bom tá bom
E se der ruim o quanto a gente tá
disposto do ruim ou o que que não né e
tudo mais e entra na
parte e se a gente entra na parte
analítica assim da coisa é muito como
que a gente coleta os fatos e do tipo
coloca a coisa lógica ali né na na
discussão é e que entra até
em às vezes pode pensar como algo não
analítico mas no storytelling né Que
história que você tá querendo contar Ou
que você tá pensando aqui quais são os
fatos que suportam ela né e e o negócio
que a gente não falou que tem a ver com
com o livro que você comentou também é
cara que premissas existem ou que forças
estão atuando dentro disso daqui que
podem modificar a
a realidade né porque o livro fala muito
sobre póker né Então esse é um exemplo
legal assim que pô Às vezes você tem uma
jogada que é correta você fazer
estatisticamente por todos os elementos
que tem mas imagina que você tá jogando
uma mão se você perder você não entra no
dinheiro naquele torneio que é quando
quando inicia a faixa de premiação
e cara é muito importante para você
entrar no dinheiro naquele torne tipo é
fazer a diferença entre você poder jogar
mais um torneio ou não sabe Cara às
vezes nesse caso é melhor você tomar a
decisão que estatisticamente é errada
porque naquela situação específica tem
outros fatores que tenam e exercem uma
força maior sobre aquela decisão sabe
então é um pouco quais premissas existem
aqui para para serem considerad total
e pensando nisso quando você acha que
foi que você começou a desenvolver
assim trazendo uma
visão de de pessoa de que tá bastante
tempo no mercado o que eu
vejo hoje eu falo assim pô isso deveria
ser uma
Skill básica tá colocando com hoje tô
falando hoje na posição que eu estou com
muitos anos de carreira e tudo mais eu
olho para trás e falo assim pô essa é
uma Skill básica E aí é o que eu tento
fortalecer meus times estruturar para
eles já sempre já terem isso na Essência
grande parte dos times que eu montei
sempre foi com isso como base mas eu sei
que dando as aulas a gente tá percebendo
que não é uma Skill que as pessoas têm
isso muito desenvolvida e aí eu parei
para para me perguntar cara quando foi
que eu fiz essa virada de chave eu
comecei a analisar isso e como isso
entrou no meu DNA assim sabe mas antes
de contar eu queria saber a sua como
como você começou a desenvolver isso tem
bastante clareza que foi numa fase bem
mais Sênior da minha carreira assim tipo
bem mais recente aqui do que no início e
aí dando alguns passos atrás né eu
comecei minha carreira em dados então
essa parte
de essa parte mais analítica e
principalmente a parte quant Eu acho que
o meu background ajudou então de novo
dividindo ent duas partes n entre a
parte crítica e a parte anal eu acho que
uma eu tinha mais desenvolvido mas ainda
assim eu fui desenvolver mais depois
sabe eu tinha uma parte dela E aí só
fazer um parêntese aí disso que você tá
falando p a parte de dados te ajudou a
ser mais
analítico Mas uma coisa que eu vejo
particularmente
em em pessoas que já tem um background
muito técnico com muito de dados é que
ela tem o analítico muito estourado
muito evoluído mas a parte crítica lá
embaixo e aí a balança fica muito
desigual porque aí ele não fica nem um
data driven é um data only tá ligado é
data only e eu acho que T vez por eu por
eu ter menos isso que eu acabei indo
para produto até porque é aquela parada
não adianta nada do dado pelo dado se
você não tá conectando aquilo com o
negócio se você não tá tirando Insight
daquilo né então eu acho que eu
conseguia fazer isso de processar
produt agora você vai falar também que
você foi para que outro dia aí você
falou né que você me bancou quando eu
fui lá pros Estados Unidos agora você
vai falar também que você foi pro
produto por causa de mim você teve
influência você teve inf você teve a
influência mas mas teve isso né mas eu
sinto que as duas coisas juntas assim eu
fui começar a desenvolver mais quando eu
já já tinha uma posição de PM s assim
pensando em cargo mesmo e para mim é
muito claro que eu me achava uma pessoa
que era boa de resolver problemas eu
resolvia problemas eh no trabalho e tal
mas eu não sabia fazer isso de forma
estruturada então não tinha um processo
Claro para aquilo eu acho que o momento
que clicou para mim de tenho que
desenvolver isso daqui
e mudou minha forma de pensar que eu
acho que é um pouco isso que você tá
falando você voltou atrás para pensar
quando você passou a dar mais
importância para ele se entender isso
como uma uma habilidade fundamental ali
foi nessa hora assim que eu falei
Beleza agora eu preciso aprender a
resolver problemas de forma estruturada
eh e foi até um p de eh Uma uma ex-líder
minha Alice que a gente já falou que NV
e que a gente precisa chamar Alice PR PR
e que eu acho que é muito curioso que é
um negócio que é muito natural para quem
fez carreira em consultoria então ma 15
bem BCG e tal A galera gosta de zoar
muito consultor né mas o trabalho do
consultor é esse resolver problema de
forma estruturada e saber colocar isso
num eh num formato e e aplicar aquilo e
eu acho que foi isso que esse driver
assim de pô beleza agora eu tenho que
aprender a fazer isso de forma
estruturada e e aprendi que foi o clique
E aí para mim é igual você assim desde
então eu falo assim cara isso é uma
esquil fundamental de produto é um
negócio que deveria puxar desde o início
e que eu acho que tem até um GAP de
Educação de produto mesmo de falar pouco
sobre isso sabe falar mais sobre outras
coisas mas e você como que foi isso que
a PR carena tá aí né cara é isso
aí mas cara eh acho que contexto né Putz
eu tive uma agência quando eu tava lá no
meu início de carreira eu fui engenheiro
de custo indústria ah mesmo fazendo ADM
E então assim desde sempre antes de
pensar em trabalhar com produto eu
acabava já fazendo essas ligações né
Essas causalidades assim de o quanto o
que que eu tô fazendo como Isso pode
impactar e o quanto isso tá conectado
financeiramente e o que que isso pode
virar depois né o quanto isso então
assim
eh olhando hoje para trás é isso sen eu
já isso já meio que tava trig indiret
ente desde cedo e aí mas para mim acho
que o grande ponto foi ter trabalhado
numa empresa de e-commerce e assim o
grande um dos grandes pulos do gato
assim quando a gente começou a crescer e
a foi foi pô
cara falando de 2014
quando comprar por aplicativo não eram
negócios como a gente faz hoje assim né
E aí a gente conseguiu fazer uma
uma uma conexão entre o quanto a gente
arrumava de Crash free impactava no no
Shared no quanto a gente vendia
literalmente sabe e Pode parecer Mega
simples assim mas foi um trick que virou
na minha uma parada que virou na minha
cabeça assim cara se a gente consegue
fazer nisso a gente deveria ter um olhar
para qualquer outra coisa também que a
gente vai fazer o quanto a gente faz
essa conexão E aí já para fazer um um
parênteses aqui Claro que não é
tudo 100% do tempo que vai fazer sentido
fazer isso mas quando você tem
minimamente começa a exercitar isso e a
ter esse olhar esse olhar crítico e
analítico você vai conseguir fazer tá
bom isso aqui faz sentido eu me
aprofundar um pouco mais e fazer essa
essa ligação essa outra parada aqui
não fazo eu acho quea a chavinha de você
come tudo como sistemas que tem entradas
processamentos e saídas assim e
alavancas então PR eu mexer nso daqui eu
tenho essa alavanca aqui que eu posso
puar para um lado ou pro outro né e a no
fim você consegue pegar vários problemas
e reduzir a isso entender Quais que são
as alavancas desse sistema
aqui quais são as alavancas como esse
sistema funciona de forma geral e o
mundo são sistemas né e eu não tô
falando aqui sistemas tecnológicos né
sistema de forma mais generalista e e
como Quais são as alavancas que que
mexem esse ponto é não E essa você falou
de sistemas uma outra parada que eu faço
que eu falo muito com relação a isso que
é tudo é um funil e e mas é nessa mesma
linha que você tá falando do sistemas
por tudo tem um início uma quantidade de
pessoas ou de coisas acontecendo que ela
passa por uma série de etapas e que no
final você vai ter ali tipo o resultado
que é quantas chegaram até o final ou
executaram até o final ou foi feito até
o final né então com isso você consegue
pô conectar muito mais as coisas e fazer
todas essas criar a o sistema no final
das contas né É E e é isso é aplicável
para eu tô procurando apartamento né
cara procurar apartamento é um funil eu
tenho que olhar tantos apartamentos
desses tantos que eu olhar eu vou gostar
de tantos desses tantos que eu gostar eu
vou mandar mensagem para tantos eu vou
visitar tantos para mandar proposta para
tantos para fechar um Então você tem que
vir fazendo essa conta né boa e aí acho
que mudando um pouco agora do do topico
como
você você enxerga que uma pessoa tá
sendo boa nisso ou tá ou minimamente tá
indo no caminho tá começando
Cara eu acho
que essa questão de você a que a quebra
do problema para mim é o é o jeito de
entender e treinar vamos dizer assim é
você pegar assim qual que é o problema
que eu tenho para resolver então qual
que é normalmente no nosso dia a dia né
de trabalho é cara que métrica que eu
tenho que mexer Qual que é a métrica
Master aqui e às vezes esse problema
essa Quebra Vai começar lá em cima que
você tem a métrica da empresa e você tem
que entender Qual que é a quebra dessa
métrica pro seu time às vezes não às
vezes já tá mais Given ali ó o seu time
é redondo desse numerozinho aqui e você
entender mas eu acho que o me diz muito
assim e até a forma como eu tenar
aprender é isso como você pega um
resultado um problema tem que resolver e
você vai fazendo essa quebrinha
e e é um negócio meio complicado de
aprender porque não de treinar vamos
dizer assim porque não tem gabarito né
não é uma conta matemática que você vai
lá e tem que dar cinco no final é tem um
pouco de falha ali na avaliação mesmo né
então às vezes você tá pegando um
problema pela primeira vez você não
entende tão bem as alavancas dele você
tem que quebrar ele você não vai ter de
cara uma visão assim esse problema
ele tá Miss por exemplo sabe eu peguei
todos os elementos esses elementos não t
overlap entre eles mas com o tempo
conforme você vai vendo o mesmo problema
outras vezes ou você vai ganhando mais
profundidade você vai voltando e e e
resolvendo né incorporando as coisas que
você aprendeu
com na sua avaliação Inicial acho que
essa
capacidade sar acho que essa capcidade
de você fazer uma quebra e você ir
corrigindo aqui as com as coisas que
você aprendeu ao longo do tempo e fica
muito mais fácil depois para você montar
os sistemas né você já vai est com você
fica com seus sistemas muito mais claros
né para começar a estruturar o
pensamento crítico e analítico né No
final das contas é e eu acho que nessa
fase Entra muito a parte analítica né
que se você tá quebrando aqui esse
problema como que você compara essas
coisas né Como que você diz pô isso aqui
eu tô comparando laranja com laranja
então eu posso dizer que isso daqui é
uma oportunidade é uma alavanca de X
milhões e essa daqui é de X milhões
menos um e talvez faça mais sentido
então atacar essa de X milhões sabe você
vai começando a pensar também como que
eu faço para saber que que tem aqui
dentro sabe qual qual que são os valores
disso E aí começar a fazer essas
conexões até com os elementos do negócio
mesmo é é que aí você já até acabou
encaixando no aliás antes a gente acabou
perguntando aqui como saber que uma
pessoa tá minimamente entendendo isso
então você falou sobre quebrar e ver
como que a pessoa tá quebrando os
problemas também como a gente faz a
provocação né falando a gente aqui como
pessoas líderes né como gestores e tudo
mais como a gente eh faz as provocações
corretas né para para criar os sistemas
também mas como você você vê que é
possível treinar isso você até falou
putz é meio complicado assim mas
eh como você enxerga que é possível dar
essa Sementinha para as pessoas
começarem a explorar isso se elas não
necessariamente conseguirem aplicar isso
tipo no dia zero na na empresa delas eu
acho para mim é um curiosidade sobre
negócio
eh e é negócio a fundo mesmo é você
pegar um Business e entender como ele
funciona como ele ganha dinheiro Quais
são os custos dele que que é custo fixo
que que é custo variável como essas
coisas se relaciona at você ter o
interesse por negócios e Ach é um pouco
do que a gente faz aqui né quando a
gente indica conteúdos eu acho que é um
pouco dessa curiosidade que a gente tem
também sobre não só produto né mas
tecnologia e negócio como um todo e acho
que é isso E aí eu tenho um Dozinho da
época que eu tive que aprender problem
solving né e acho que a coisa na
internet mais próxima disso que você
pode pegar para treinar é Business cases
então é você pegar cases de São
tradicionalmente cases de MBA assim que
são no fim eh quebras de negócio né
então é basicamente isso eu acho que
isso te ajuda um a entender como um
negócio funciona e quais as alavancas
por aí para quando você pegar um que
você tem que fazer por conta própria
você ter repertório você falar assim
isso aqui é parecido com essa outra
coisa ou isso aqui é exatamente igual
outra coisa ti eu tava explicando o Dia
D trabalho como quebrar um negócio de
assinaturas porque um negócio de
assinatura é basicamente um negócio de
Lifetime velho e aí Lifetime velho ele
só existe dois jeitos de você aumentar
ou você aumenta o Lifetime ou você
aumenta o velho e aí você vai quebrando
então o que que tá dentro de Lifetime Ah
isso isso isso que que tá dentro de
velho isso isso isso E aí no final eu
vdei pra pessoa e falei assim daqui pra
frente o resto da sua vida essa é a
forma que você quebra qualquer negócio
de assinatura independente do que ele
seja tá ligado Então a estrutura básica
de um produto de assinatura é isso mas
por que que eu se isso porque eu trabal
um monte de produto de assinatura na
vida e f ganhando no repertório com isso
pegar um problema que eu nunca vi no
universo muito diferente eu não vou ter
o repertório ainda então acho que esse
consumo de negócios mesmo e é o que vai
te dar esse repertório para na hora que
você se vê numa situação você ter
minimamente um caminho para por onde
começar sabe uhum bo Então acho que tem
de dicas aqui como que eu treino um
curiosidade sobre negócios
definitivamente é isso entender e tals e
tem uma outra dica que a gente fal mais
com detalhes no curso Então a para dear
que é fazer exercícios do DM né também
que é é isso vocês Pode pedir pro chat
GPT lá e tal mas a gente fala mais sobre
isso lá no curso e aí você acabou
engatando eu ia falar isso do chat GPT
só que você falou porque ele pode ser um
parceiro para isso para ele ir avaliando
você fazer um Business Case junto com
ele ir te avaliando pode ser não seja a
coisa mais precisa do mundo mas ele vai
te ajudar te direcionar ali sabe
definitivamente E aí você já conectou
com um outro bloco com a outra parada
que pra gente falar que é ISO né é a
curiosidade sobre negócios que é o que
eu sempre falo há muito tempo que é
assim cara vai entrar num numa empresa
primeira coisa que é como que essa
empresa ganha dinheiro como que a roda
gira Néa como que ela ganha dinheiro
como que ela perde Quais são as teses eh
pô quem tá fazendo o que como tá fazendo
como os concorrentes fazem como os conc
como tipo empresas que fazem a mesma
coisa similar fora do Brasil ou tipo em
outros mercados fazem Então se inscrever
nas News L lá de quem cobra esse mercado
que você tá entrando são tudo maneiras
para você antes de você começar o tático
né cara porque com isso você vai saber
vai te ajudar até na hora de da tomada
de decisões né se pô faz sentido se
aprofundar nisso ou não faz sentido se
aprofundar nisso eh isso aqui é
diferencial ou isso aqui é commodity é
Então acho que tem várias dessas coisas
e aí um outro ponto que é se você tá se
você sabe o que que o seu time precisa
fazer você tá igual no mercado é o
básico do básico precisa fazer se você
sabe como o seu as coisas que o seu time
faz impactam no Business da compania
você já tá eu vou falar uns 50% na
frente de grande parte das pessoas dos
PMs tô exagerando e se você sabe como
que a empresa como um todo funciona como
o mercado como um todo funciona o
mercado que você está
inserido cara você tá aí eu vou falar
que você tá uns
90% na frente do do tipo do Óbvio tá
ligado eu tava no mudo aqui mas quando
você falou 50% você tava exagerando não
acho que você tá até puxando para baixo
na real e
para mim é o 90% nos dois assim mas eu
que é e o o Igor que é CEO da pia né
trabalhei lá H um tempo e ele tinha uma
frase que ele me falou uma vez que que
eu sempre lembro No Limite eh cada
iniciativa de produto cada objetivo ali
de produto deveria est conectada numa
linha do dre da empresa Então você como
PM deveria saber explicar fazer as
conexões para cima ali de Como aquela
coisa que você tá fazendo volta pro pro
dre da empresa sabe que no fim é como
você tá olhando o negócio né como no fim
você tiver numa empresa aberta na bolsa
o que os investidores estão olhando no
fim do dia é a contabilidade é o dre
é o top line o bot online e tudo que
tudo que tá ali no meio como você você
consegue como pessoa de produto conectar
isso is inclusive vai te ajudar a galgar
posições sabe porque quanto mais você
sobe na carreira de produto mais você
chega perto das carreiras executivas e
nas carreiras executivas cara você tá a
gente fala aqui o tempo todo né Você tá
conversando na linguagem do negócio não
é mais a linguagem ali só do produto né
e a linguagem do negócio vai ser 90% do
tempo ela vai ser ou como você aumenta a
receita ou como você reduz o custo né
tentando simplificar o máximo mas sem
querer simplificar vai ser sobre isso
então quanto mais você conseguir
conversar nessa língua mais você vai
conseguir fazer as análises de impacto
né do seu produto
eh é isso
aí como você faz essas como você
comunica isso com outras áreas Porque
grande parte das outras áreas a gente já
falou isso em tr00 episódios aqui também
falam dessa língua E aí às vezes do tipo
ah as outras áreas comão com ranço de
tecnologia no geral porque a galera tá
preocupada mais em falar isso a story
points da Sprint
Eh quantas Sprint quinzenal é do tipo
Discovery e tal essas coisas e menos
sobre o end game no final das contas né
Essas coisas aqui não que elas não sejam
importantes mas a discussão sobre elas é
menos na parte é menos importante do que
de fato o reduzir custos e aumentar
receita né
No Limite é para que você tá construindo
o que você tá construindo sabe
é vai virar o qu depois é isso os estão
mais acostumados com isso e às vezes a
gente esquece né a gente vive numa bolha
Tec produto às vezes acaba isolada do
resto da empresa nesse sentido quanto
operações tá ali falando de custos
direto produto tecnologia que é research
né resarch ela gente não tá conectando o
que eles estão fazendo com com osos da
empresa é E aí se você quer começar a
usar isso na sua empresa no seu time
coisas que acho que vale recomendar
primeiro que é a primeira rodada as
primeiras rodadas sempre vão ser uma
conta de
padeiro você vai assumir um monte de
número e Ok contando que seja combinado
com os outros as outras áreas e com quem
vai est olhando issoo eu sofri muito com
isso sabia eu era eu era por vir de
dados eu queria muito ter o número mais
preciso possível e tambi muita martelada
até falar cara não contra de padeiro na
maior parte das vezes vai ser o guren
ali sabe exato e porque assim não faz
sentido tipo um time usar uma um número
pra mesma coisa e um outro time usar um
outro outro e a nenhum fizer não vai
fazer sentido até trazendo um exemplo na
Loft quando a gente começou a fazer a
gente chamava lá de dollar Impact
e para uma umas iniciativas específicas
lá a gente ia implementar um novo o tipo
de casas né assim que a gente só tinha
apartamento no primeiro Loft e
apartamentos no primeiro momento e aí a
gente Tomou como a gente colocou como
premissa o ticket médio que a gente a
gente meio que tinha assim PR casas e
tudo mais mas a gente assumiu a gente
não sabia que é exatamente mas aquilo
ajudou a gente a tipo ter uma baliza
para todos os times falarem na mesma
linguagem e depois a gente tunou quando
a gente de fato viu aquilo ah sendo a
entrega daquilo de Fato né então é isso
assumam a as balizas e alinhem que essa
baliza vai ser a mesma e aí é interar
não tem jeito assim porque o
provavelmente os primeiros os chutes vão
est muito altos mas depois com cada
rodada você vai tunando e o legal é
fazer o antes e o depois justamente para
você ter isso né cara a gente achou que
ia impactar tanto mas na verdade
impactou tanto pô impactou tanto a gente
foi muito pessimista a gente foi muito
realista ou a gente foi cara otimista
até demais então e aí vai te ajudar isso
a fazer a baliza pra próxima né E aí vai
te dando esse repertório e esse tunning
né No final das contas é eu eu acho que
como pessoa de produto toda vez que e
como l de falar assim ah treinar problem
solving e e parte analítica acho que a
parte mais importante era o learn by
doing A iteração então tipo eu não quero
que você pegue esse problema quebre ele
estruture ele sozinho eu quero que você
faça que depois a gente converse junto e
a gente vai iterando e a gente vai
conversar com outras pessoas e aí você
vai voltando e reorganizando and sabe
reestruturando então é isso não é um
negócio que vou fazer de cara e tem
que est certo 100% porque o certo certo
mesmo não existe aqui talvez até certo
nível ele exista até certo nível você
consegue quebrar bem tranquilo assim as
alavancas para elas não terem overlap
entre elas chega uma parte ali cara não
tem como sabe deixa de ser produtivo
passa a ser contraprodutivo e E aí vai
muito do julgamento das pessoas esse
julgamento se você puder fazer em
conjunto com pessoas tem experiência é o
melhor jeito de você aprender é isso e
assim Bom falamos um monte né temos
dicas e recomendações aí de para quem
quer aprofundar mais nesse assunto além
de fazer os cursos né que a gente vai
deixar as datas aqui eu tenho eu tenho
algumas coisas aqui então vai fala aí
fala aí fala aí primeiro acho que a
gente pode deixar aí no no link do
episódio eu falei que eu tenho um DOC de
de quando eu tive que estudar
e eu posso deixar ele disponível cara
nada mais é do que links interessantes
que eu encontrei e que me ajudaram a
estruturar aqui então e vocês vão ver
quem abrir esse doc tem muito conteúdo
de consultoria como eu falei as pessoas
de consultoria estratégica elas são
treinadas para fazer isso de forma
estrutural então procurem material uma
15 BCG é b Company que que tem bastante
coisa fora isso acho que a gente falou
também bastante sobre sistemas né Artur
acho que tem um livro legal sobre isso
que é o Thinking in Systems eu não sei
se ele tem versão em português li ele em
inglês mas se tiver a gente deixa o link
aí também é depois que você ler ele você
vai ver a Matrix assim no mundo e como
tudo são sistemas basicamente e por
último do meu lado aqui uma recomendação
zinha de site barra ferramenta aqui que
eu acho que a gente já falou que é o
antus eh
anus.co e ele tem ali uma lista de
Framework zinhos de de problem solving
de tomada de decisão que às vezes você
tá com um negócio na mão você quer ali
um negócio para você começar a
estruturar aquilo Entra lá no antus ver
que que melhor se encaixa E aí isso já
te dá um um Norte e eu acho que o chat é
pt que a gente falou aqui acho que fo é
uma boa também ter essas interações e
conversando pode ser um um jeito aí de
você rampar também você Artur tem coisas
aí ten cara acho que um a gente já falou
tem vou tentar compilar um pouquinho
condensar aqui o que a gente falou
anteriormente acho que um tem o o outro
livro que é o Thinking bats a gente já
comentou sobre ele em alguns Episódios
aqui né Já falamos sobre ele tem
inclusive um um episódio do podcast do
Len que a gente também sempre recomenda
aqui com a a Duke que é autora do do
livro e ela comenta bastante sobre esse
sobre esses processos então acho que é
relevante o que eu já falei em cima
também
eh exercícios de Mat também podem ajudar
ajudar nisso e estudar um pouco também
sobre correlação versus
causalidade também é um ponto bem
relevante que que faz sentido e o outro
que você falou também e só pra gente
fechar aqui que é curiosidade né
curiosidade de um exercício que eu que
eu adoro de fazer
e seja para qualquer coisa por exemplo
Ah quero pô beleza vou mapear um produto
mapear que as que eventos que eu teria
num produto aí pô qual o produto que eu
mais uso aqui ah vou pegar ele aqui e
vou fazer do trás pra frente Putz beleza
Qual é imagina só o PM dessa parte aqui
pô qual o evento que seria legal o que
que eu
analiso mas estou dando esse exemplo
para faça isso com para não ser um
negócio massante e que em determinado
momento vai ser tá até para deixar claro
aqui que não sempre vai ser legal mas
tipo os produtos que você gosta Analisa
como que eles ganham dinheiro Quais são
as métricas importantes para eles
chegarem nisso assim e como que é esse
processo que que você como que você acha
que é estruturado a empresa para chegar
nesses pontos super simples mas tipo
você vai treinando E aí usa o chot de
APT ou então pega os e as cartas de
investidores também das empresas que
estão na bolsa tambm Eu ia falar isso
mano toda empresa aberta em bolsa e tem
que divulgar os resultados
trimestralmente e você pode ir lá isso é
aberto então pegar empresas que TM a ver
com o setor que você trabalha ou o setor
que você tem interesse outra coisa que
eu fazia também que eu acho interessante
é ler os S ones que são os Docs que as
empresas que vão fazer IPO precisam
preencher que basicamente o S1 é uma é
um cal papel para assim é um Dock
gigantesco mas que cara é uma baita
explicação do negócio que é basicamente
a empresa explicando pro mercado O que é
aquele negócio a história todos os
resultados até agora qual que é a tese
que eles esperam dali pra frente então
para para startups assim que muita gente
tem interesse né pegar os S1 e e ver ali
e toda essa explicação tamb é um é um
negócio bem legal para você ir a fundo
nesse entendimento de negócio é e lógico
para terminar você pode escolher como
você vai querer aprender com a gente
também vai ter o curso online e ao vivo
dia 29/06 e vai ter o curso presencial
dia
6/07 então fica aí vai ser num sábado os
dois um dia inteiro pra gente falar um
monte só disso é isso agora vamos falar
dos produtos da semana Bora
[Música]
lá o produo semana foi calculadora por
conta
de Aí é
Ai ai começa aí qual que é o seu
produto da semana meu querido não você
tá pedi para eu começar porque você não
colocou o seu aqui ainda né você é um
danado olha só
cara eu vou falar eu tô trabalhando
muito nessas últimas semanas né Eu acho
que dentro do trabalhando muito Eu
passei boa parte do meu tempo dentro de
planilha mano então acho que o Google
sheets é porque a gente tem uma
ferramenta que é interna da hotm a
ferramenta de dados chama astrobox então
basei bastante tempo dentro do astrobox
Mas essa é só interna e a a ferramenta
externa que eu usei muito foi o Google
sheets para caramba e aí só falar um
negócio que a gente não falou nada de e
essa semana mas
o junto com o GPT 4 o lá que lançou a
Open fez melhorias também na parte de
análise de dados do chat GPT E agora dá
para você conectar diretamente com
documentos do Google Drive ou do
onedrive e ele tá um analista de dados
muito melhor tem um post lá no no no
site da Open ai então você agora a
anilha abre você pode interagir nela por
dentro do chat CPT tá bem mais
interativo tá parece eu não não testei
muito a fundo ainda liberou para mim
hoje é essa parte e cara pode ser uma
baita mão na roda pra análise de dados
Mais até do que já era então vou testar
aí e trago notícias nas próximas semanas
Olha só olha só
é mas eu eu tô na mesma linha aí na na
na stc das últimas semanas
ntec HTEC do Trabalhador moderno do
noled worker moderno é o planilha
e
PPT eu fico muito feliz que na na hotm a
gente tem uma cultura mais documento
escrito e menos PPT eu odeio fazer PPT
velho é ai cara mas tipo para condensar
informação eu acho que é mais mais fácil
o PPT do que o
o o texto velho e aí eu gosto também do
texto escrito e tudo mais mas assim fica
mas assim usei bastante e é e aí como
que é uma linguagem Universal né cara O
PPT
assim e e e também tem um que até a
gente já falou em outros episódios aqui
do lance de como você é conciso na na
mensagem porque o um slide ele te obriga
a condensar a informação e fazer essa do
tipo a síntese ou o resumo quando for o
caso os bullets e tal mas que seja um
negócio prático né então façam slides
com 1 milhão de coisas fonte 11
eh cinco gráficos diferente três seta um
parágrafo qu tu falou slide tem que ser
conciso
né a gente tá muito do trabalhador mesmo
velho vamos ver se os nossos ouvintes
trouxeram apps mais interessantes aí do
que os nosos Pois é trouxeram cara a
Pilão mandou o drink water que é o app
para acompanhar ali a tomada da água eu
tenho um outro eu uso um de água também
que eu acho que eu já até falei um
episódio aqui deixa eu ver como que el
chama eu bebo muita água eu não preciso
de PR isso não eu tomo bastante mas eu
gosto porque eu né Eu gosto de mensurar
bastante as coisas então eu tenho no meu
relógio ou aplic na na tela principal
tem aqui toda hora que eu acabo de tomar
uma água eu vou lá e pum mais mais 500
ml 350 ml eh que é o drink o que eu uso
é o o waterminder mas o que a pilon
mandou é o drink water a Natasha mandou
o late driver
eh ela usa
no interior e vou até falar exatamente
aqui o que que ela
falou ela tem que tem no interior de São
Paulo e que tem uns bugzinho mas
funciona melhor e ela confia melhor do
que o Uber
eh o danilera mandou o Brawl Stars
joguinho aí e o beola mandou o Class
pass que ele falou que por mais que
pareça ser um pouquinho mais caro que o
o o como que ficou o nome o novo nome do
jque nome sabe o que que é engraçado o o
ícone mudou para well Hub mas o nome do
app ainda no celular é de o que eu achei
uma excelente sacada porque quando eu
vou buscar aqui para fazer meu chequinho
eu não lembro que é o El já começa a
deitadinho em pés e aí eu acho é e e é
uma estratégia de ASO né de App Store
optimization aí e caraca relembrei meus
tempos aqui de de mobile Mas enfim que
tem que tem várias opções e várias
coisas lá legais no Ah e
mais é isso continue mandando pra
[Música]
gente e com isso a gente encerra o
programa de hoje né mais uma vez aqui
recadinhos de sempre Sigam a gente no
seu tocador de Podcast podcast Favorito
Spotify YouTube
substack qualquer lugar aí que você ouve
podcast se curtiu a discussão dessa
semana ou qualquer outro Episódio
recomenda Manda aí para um amiguinho
para um companheiro de trabalho eh um
episódio do papo na arena fala para ele
ouvir pô pode ver lá no YouTube zero
eh fricção aí de ter que baixar um
podcast ou coisa do tipo então recomenda
aí ajuda isso ajuda para caramba o
podcast a crescer e atingir mais pessoas
e segue a gente nas redes né Instagram
Twitter LinkedIn trads eu sou @x em
todos os lugares O Artur é o @arthur
Close comk e nossa casa aí o @ product
Arena que a gente tá sempre fazendo lá
as enquetes de produto da semana
divulgando os episódios repostando
quando vocês mandam lá marcam a gente né
ouv no podcast então façam isso também
que a gente reposta lá e semana que vem
tem mais é isso semana que vem estamos
de volta
e a gente se vê se ouve na arena é isso
valeu valeu